una semana de caos el 15 de agosto se
anunció la entrada a kabul del talibán
el grupo insurgente no se topó con
resistencia alguna las fuerzas de
seguridad afganas abandonaron la ciudad
tras conocer que el presidente a strauss
kahn había huido del país desde el
palacio presidencial el talibán anunció
que la guerra había terminado pese a la
ola de críticas el presidente de eeuu
defendió su decisión de retirar las
tropas a quienes
los líderes políticos afganos se
rindieron y huyeron del país los
militares afganos se derrumbaron a veces
sin intentar luchar
la desesperación se apoderó de cientos
de afganos que buscaban salir del país a
toda costa algunos murieron intentando
colgarse de las aeronaves
estadounidenses en pleno despegue
el talibán celebró una primera
conferencia de prensa confirmando que
respetarían los derechos de las mujeres
según la ley sharia
queremos un gobierno y un sistema futuro
que incluya a personas de todos los
pensamientos no queremos más guerra
queremos la paz en afganistán
el 19 de agosto cientos de afganos
salieron a las calles de kabul a
celebrar 102 años de independencia del
imperio británico la bandera tricolor
afgana se convirtió en símbolo de
resistencia pero las protestas
terminaron con muertes civiles a manos
de los extremistas mientras el mundo
comenzaba a preocuparse por una nueva
inminente crisis de refugiados afganos
el cofundador del talibán entraba kabul
iniciando contactos con miras a la
formación de un nuevo gobierno según la
otan más de 20 personas murieron en las
inmediaciones del aeropuerto de kabul en
una semana mientras continúan las
evacuaciones el talibán que señala a
washington como responsable del caos
anunció reuniones con líderes
provinciales un nuevo liderazgo cuyo
rostro de moderación no resulta creíble
para la comunidad internacional